hey what's up my name's samuel leeds and
on this video i'm going to be giving you
all my secrets
to property investing i've been
investing in property for over 12 years
you know how you invest successfully in
property the very first thing you need
to do
if you want to be a millionaire very
first step is
to smash the like button on this video
that would be absolutely amazing so go
ahead
smash the like button i'm going to be
answering people's property investment
questions from last sunday
and then i'm going to be answering your
questions as well all you need to do is
comment below
and i'll answer them for free you don't
have to pay me all you need to do
smash the like button and of course
subscribe to the channel that would be
amazing let's see what we've got from
last week
alexander ppg says hi samuel how can i
can you please tell us what we can do
after when the agents
don't work for instance how do you get
more leads
in rent to rent which websites to use to
send messages
build contacts and etc that will be
needed to start to grow one's business
many thanks okay so if you're looking to
do rent to rent
fine you can go to the estate agents if
that doesn't work
my suggestion would be to continue doing
it i mean
the biggest reason people fail is
because it doesn't work and then they
quit people like me saying
i've been exercising at the gym i've
been eating healthy
i did it the whole day yesterday and i'm
still fat
it's not working i mean as well quit you
need to keep doing it as part of the
process
so keep speaking to estate agents and
every time you do it you're going to get
better
and also at the same time if you want to
speak to landlords direct you can go to
spare room
code at uk you can go to open rent you
can go to gumtree there's so many
websites there's so many leads on there
where you can contact landlords direct
and just keep doing it persistence is
kink hope that helps
next by the way i hope you liked the
video by now remember that's the first
step to being a millionaire smash the
like button
all right next um rick talon hi samuel
just finished watching your entire q a
sunday playlist wow that's
that's commitment respect i hope you
liked every video
great content obviously i have a
question i hope to hear your take on it
for info i'm based in scotland would
like to use your local mortgage broker
tax accountant etc as scotland has a
divergent tax system or if investing
across the country
use online brokers solicitors etc
totally agree with agent nearby thank
you kindly paul
uh okay paul so i think what you're
saying is should you be using
local should your power team
i.e your solicitors your brokers your
accountants
be local to your house where you live or
should you be using people online that
are far away and the answer is a little
bit of both
so of course as you've said for your
management company
if they're managing your properties you
want to be really close to your
properties
your accountants your solicitors your
brokers doesn't really matter
i mean you might need to meet up with
them occasionally to sign paperwork and
stuff but generally speaking
if they're a couple of hours away it's
no problem just make sure you get on
with them
make sure they're investing in property
themselves and make sure they're
solution finders not problem finders so
as long as they understand what you're
doing and they understand the laws
within your country you can literally
use people
anywhere and sometimes people like i
need an accountant near my house
you don't you can use one a couple hours
away it's no problem so that'll be my
advice
hope that helps all right ryan ellison
says i'm looking at starting
my investing soon could you quickly go
through the quick steps
quick quick quick of the order to get
things in place such as
registering the limited company creating
a bank account for the company finding
an accountant finding a lender et cetera
many thanks for your content
ryan um i remember when i was a kid and
i wanted to i wanted to learn karate
and i asked for christmas for a karate
kit i got the kit
i got the little white belt had the
outfit had the
the scripts watched karate kid on tv but
guess what i never actually ended up
doing any karate and in the same way in
business sometimes you can get the
company
get the accountant get the business
cards get the perfect logo
that's not what you need what you need
is to find deals
when you start finding deals you find a
house you want to buy
damn i want to buy the house am i going
to buy my own name or in a company maybe
i need to quickly set company up
you can set a company up within 24 hours
so just find the deal sometimes it's an
excuse not to go make the money you
don't need a freaking accountant
an accountant's job is to save you tax
on the money that you earn but if you're
not earning any money
don't stop paying for an accountant
maybe have a meeting with an accountant
to get a general
first consultation of a plan but just
start making money
focus on money making activities only
like how i should have focused on karate
instead of getting the kit all right
next
red rooster a question on my behalf
i've spoken with okay i'm a full-time
single parent currently relying entirely
on the state i'm permanently
semi-exhausted because of caring for
small children
and no external help however i'm
intelligent willing to work
smart within my limited available time
what is an optional strategy to first
get extra income to pay for help with
cleaning and shopping
babysitting etc to free up my time to
move into stage two for financial
independence
um redwood i'd probably recommend if
you're just looking for a little bit of
extra money
to help you while you're looking after
your kid maybe you just need maybe you
just need a part-time job
um i mean property investment listen
you've
in property you've got two choices you
can be an investor in other words
you need money or other people's money
to invest in property or you be an
entrepreneur a property entrepreneur
rent to rent deal packaging if you're an
investor
you need funds or you need someone
else's funds if you're an entrepreneur
you need time you need blood sweat and
tears you need to roll your sleeves up
so if you're saying i just need a little
bit of extra money to help with cleaning
products and stuff
then maybe you just need a part-time job
and and if you've already got a
part-time job
maybe you need to say to your employer
hey how can i be more valuable to you
how can i become more valuable to you
and you need to get work use your
intelligence and your smartness
to become more valuable to then get paid
more so
that having my general advice i hope
that helps i don't know if that's what
you wanted to hear
but um yeah smash the like button anyway
online boss hey bro in one of your
videos you said hmo wouldn't work in the
area your house was in
could you give me a macro description on
what kind of areas hmo will work
and what areas it will not work in so
hmos will work anywhere where you can
rent out rooms
and you'll be able to rent out rooms
anywhere where there's jobs and there's
people and there's poppingness
so if a city if if you are in a city
okay anywhere where there's a city
there's jobs there's people there's
things
if there's a hmo within walking distance
or a short bus journey of that city
you're going to be able to rent rooms
out general rule of thumb
if you're in a council estate and you're
a 10 minute drive from the nearest co-op
it is not going to work for a hmo so
that's that that's a rule of thumb and
as the support
says what's the first things you need in
terms of knowledge to start a buy to let
business
the first things you need to start
buying to that business in terms of
knowledge would be
okay buy to let buy two let you need to
know
how to work out what the let what the
rent is going to be
buy you need to be able to buy low and
you need to be able to calculate the
return on investment
if you know how to calculate the return
on investment you know how to negotiate
a good price and know what the true
value is
and be able to calculate what the true
rent is and figure out how to divide
those two together and work out the
return on investment
that's the first step first thing you
need to know in terms of knowledge
daniel aleku do you organize crash
courses are they online now
i do organize property investors crash
courses we're not running at the moment
because of the government because of the
restrictions
however we are running them online and
you can do the crash course online
for free if you're a samuel 365 member
if you are not a samuel 365 member it's
195 pounds
it's an incredible course if you are a
samuel 365 member you can do it for free
and you can become a samuel 365 member
for a one pound
trial and then thereafter it's 95 pound
a month hope that helps
okay um jagat
i'm jags i have two bites left houses i
wanted to know what's the difference
between buy to let house
to buy a company name and a person's
name or
also if i didn't work can i get a salary
for my buy to let
rent please um okay so the difference
between buying a property in a company
and in
as an individual is very simply as
exactly as we say if you the individual
buys the house
the property is owned by you the person
that's okay
many of my houses are owned by me the
person that's okay however
there are tax advantages to you setting
up a company
and the company owning the house instead
you still own the house because you own
the company there are tax advantages
they didn't used to be tax advantages it
used to be it used to be better for the
individual to own the property
now there's more tax reasons to buy it
through a company
can you draw a salary if you're making
profit of course you can
if if the properties are written out
well yeah you can take a salary and if
you have a company
you can take a salary i'm not a tax
advisor but you don't pay tax on the
first eleven thousand pounds
there's also tax advantages to taking
the salary from
the company as well so um check check
with your accountant
uh about the structure i say that to to
jags because jags has already got
properties so he can go and pay for an
account no problem if you haven't got
any
properties don't stop paying for
business cards logo design websites
accountant
don't do that just get deals if you're
gonna be paying anyone anything you
should be paying someone to teach you
how to get deals
because you need money making activities
jade says
just a quick question do you need to
have a hm mortgage on a hmo property if
you have a buy to that mortgage can you
rent it out as a hmo or do you need to
change the mortgage
so a mortgage is a mortgage is a
mortgage a mortgage is very simply
a loan to you now that loan may
have restrictions and the so if you've
got a house and you've got a mortgage on
it
i.e if a bank has loaned you money and
the house is
collateral and there's now a charge on
that house that's what a mortgage is
it might be that the bank or the lender
says to i'll give you the money on the
house
as long as you don't do this that and
the other with the house
so if you've got a general standard buy
to let mortgage it might well be that
the lender has said
i'll lend you the money you can rent the
house out but don't rent it out
room by room don't rent it out as a
service accommodation
so you just need to make sure that you
check what the terms and conditions are
with the lender it might be that you
have a buy to let mortgage and if you're
doing is a big
proper hmo sure you you're probably
gonna need
um you're gonna need a mortgage that's
fit for purpose but i've had properties
that are just standard buy to let
properties and i thought
i want to rent them out room by room
i've spoke to the lender and the lender
said that's fine
consent to let room by room consent so
just
speak to the lender it varies and make
sure that you are not
renting it out against or in breach of
any terms with the lender
but remember don't over complicate this
a mortgage is a mortgage
liam if i use a strategy whereby i offer
my investor a fixed return of 10 and use
this money for deposits is this payable
to the investor
is this payab is this payment to the
investor tax deductible
so i think your question is does the
so you're given 10 or is it they're
gonna have to pay tax on that money
so if you're paying them they're gonna
have to pay tax on
any money they receive but that's not
your problem that's their problem i
think i've understood the question right
if not comment again
helping hands i'm pregnant
congratulations
and we'll be having my first child in
december i
have finally got on the council social
housing list and intend to patiently
bid until i am offered a home in london
i then plan to use the right to buy
to purchase it at a discounted rate once
i become eligible and then rent it out
this is my plan to get on the property
ladder in london is this the long way of
doing things am i hindering myself from
pursuing other opportunities to go down
this road is right to buy still a thing
helping hands right to buy is still the
thing is it a good thing i think yes
i've known i know a lot of people that
have done right to buy they've bought
their properties they've bought the
council house that they've lived in and
they've bought it very very discounted
whether i would move in to a council
house rent because you've got to rent it
for several years before you have the
right to buy it and by then they might
have changed the rules so i probably
wouldn't personally
if you haven't even got anywhere yet i
probably wouldn't move in
and then wait years with the view of
hopefully getting a discount one day
however right to buy is good it is a
thing and it is very good i mean most of
the government schemes are shams right
to buy is one that i am
an advocate for jess x can you talk
about the pros and cons of help
help to buy okay health to buy is very
different from right to buy
health to buy in my opinion is a sham
right to buy
is great so help to buy um listen i've
done a whole video about help to buy
maybe i'll leave that in the card
and also put it in the description help
to buy is when the government
lends you money to buy a property and
you have to pay them back
but you can only buy a property that you
live in yourself and it has to be a new
build it's just
it's i don't think it's great right to
buy is different because you can rent
the property out
it's a genuine discount you're not
borrowing money from the government
so right to buy is great help to buy is
not great however of course it always
depends on what you want
you need to think what do i want and
if i i know some people have have sworn
by and go actually
help devise really help me out okay fair
enough i'm not going to argue with your
experience
my opinion it sucks peter weaver
i'm currently doing cmap course to try
to jump into some sort of job ordering
industry before i begin investing
fully as i don't know when the average
property investor becomes financially
stable enough to go full time in
property
do i need one hmo 2 by delete properties
or even two refinance deals a year what
is the average for someone like me
to finally leave the nine-to-five job uh
peter that's an impossible question to
answer because it depends
you can leave the nine-to-five job with
no properties and you can just package
and sell one deal a month
the average deal a month will get you
two to three two or three grand
leave your job tomorrow and then find
one deal a month to pass to an investor
you've replaced your income if you're
wanting to get passive income
i know people that have got i was just
chatting with a guy literally about half
an hour ago
who got one deal and he's making six
thousand pounds a month from that one
deal
and he's gonna pull all his money out
and refinance if you've got a single
let's you might only be making 200 quid
a month from each single letter so
it really really depends but the first
thing is
how much money do you need to quit your
job let's say you need two grand a month
great you need two grand a month how are
you going to get that
so it's very very bespoke all right last
one
um arubarus hi samuel i currently live
in a two bed flat and decent area of
manchester and have sixty thousand
pounds equity in it i'm thinking about
moving out letting it out for 800 pounds
a month and renting a cheaper flat to
live in
i'd like to pull my money out to buy a
second place to let but honestly don't
have a clue
i've watched some of your content around
brrr but i still don't understand the
refinancing part when you say
just remortgage the property what
exactly are the steps
very simple if you've got equity in your
property most people think when they
think of
a mortgage they think i'm going to get a
mortgage to
buy a house and you can do that but all
a mortgage is
is it's a loan against a house
so if you already own a house and you've
got equity in it
you can speak to a mortgage company and
you can say hey i already own the house
can i please borrow money against the
house and you can then have a charge on
the property and if there's already a
mortgage on it you can say
hey can i have a bigger mortgage and i'm
going to use some of the new mortgage
to pay off the old mortgage and then the
difference
i'll keep that is tax free money because
you don't pay tax on debt
and you can use it to reinvest into
property and to grow
your portfolio hope that helps thank you
so much for watching as i said
first step to being a millionaire smash
the like button subscribe to the channel
can't wait to hear your questions
comment your questions below and i'll be
answering your questions next week
thanks again
see you real soon
[Music]
you